und jetzt das heute journal
mit gundula gause und marietta slomka
es ist ein tag an dem die deutsche
wirtschaft für besondere schlagzeilen
sorgt angefangen mit dem kahlschlag bei
kaufhof und karstadt
das mehr als 60 ihrer filialen
aufgegeben werden müssen wird das bild
unserer innenstädte verändern zum
kaufhof gehen
das war eine deutsche tradition alles
unter einem dach das war ursprünglich
eine geniale idee
doch ihre blütezeit haben die großen
warenhäuser ja schon lange hinter sich
die korona bedingten schließungen haben
vielen den rest gegeben aber die
wirtschaftlichen probleme waren vorher
schon gewaltig man erinnere sich an die
karstadt pleite vor mehr als zehn jahren
und nun werden wieder viele menschen
ihren arbeitsplatz verlieren und kunden
eine vertraute adresse oliver reichert
berichtet heute am frühen nachmittag in
worms die kunden wollen einkaufen doch
galeria karstadt kaufhof hat geschlossen
heute mittag wurde ist den beschäftigten
verkündet der konzern löst diese filiale
auf das sind die organisatorischen
gründen gelernt und sind hier alt
geworden als ich finde es sehr schade
für worms weil in worms haben wir jetzt
wenig einkaufsmöglichkeit die großen
warenhäuser
sie sind in der schwersten krise ihrer
geschichte dabei haben sie große zeiten
erlebt in den 20er jahren und dann in
westdeutschland während des
wirtschaftswunders waren sie der dreh-
und angelpunkt jeder stadt
dann aber begann der abstieg mit der
zeit wurden aus den vielen namen porten
hertie quelle karstadt kaufhof immer
weniger schillernden manager wie thomas
mittel auf oder der investor nicolas
berggruen kamen und gingen und in
kaufhäusern ging es immer schlechter
zum schluss gibt es nur noch eines
galeria karstadt kaufhof in besitz des
auch schillernden immobilie mila des
rené benko aus österreich der uns ein
management greifen jetzt durch die
zentrale nachricht mehr als ein drittel
der 172 karstadt galeria kaufhof
filialen wird geschlossen
das heißt 62 häuser stehen vor dem aus
überall in der republik das bedeutet für
mehr als 6.000 mitarbeiterinnen und
mitarbeiter die entlassung für sie soll
jetzt abfindungen und sechs monate
übergang in einer transfergesellschaft
geben
es gilt jetzt für diese menschen alles
zu unternehmen dass möglichst viele
standorte trotz der liste noch gesichert
werden können dass die menschen
perspektiven bekommen dass die
beschäftigten eine absicherung bekommen
rückzugsgefechte eines gewerkschafters
besonders getroffen hat karstadt kaufhof
die korona krise wohl eine milliarde
euro an umsatz ging verloren
schon im april hatte man ein
schutzschirm verfahren beantragt eine
vorstufe zu einem insolvenzverfahren
und dann hat das unternehmen seit der
zusammenlegung von karstadt und kaufhof
vor anderthalb jahren an vielen
standorten zwei filialen wenig
nachhaltig an manchen standorten wie
hier in essen werden allerdings gleich
zwei häuser dicht gemacht
überraschend war dass beide häuser
geschlossen wird man konnte sich
vielleicht denken dass ein haus
geschlossen wird aber dass beide häuser
geschlossen werden damit hat keiner
am montag haben die gläubiger das wort
wenn sie zustimmen wird sich dann
vielleicht auch das management äußern
noch zur valerie haller in frankfurt
weil diese rosskur jetzt bei den
filialen wird das den reichen um galeria
karstadt kaufhof überhaupt wieder auf
die beine zu bringen
vermutlich wird das nicht reichen die
kaufhäuser stecken ja es wurde schon
erwähnt schon lange in der krise und die
pandemie war ja letztendlich nur der
auslöser für die schließungen
besonders junge leute kaufen ja seit
jahren lieber woanders ein auch viel im
internet ein trend den kaufhof und
karstadt verschlafen haben
das schutzschirm verfahren macht es dem
management jetzt leichter harte
einschnitte durchzuziehen aber nur
filialen zu schließen
das wird den konzern wohl nicht aus der
krise holen die große aufgabe des
managements wird es sein ein konzept zu
finden für ein modernes kaufhaus mit
guter beratung kaufen muss wieder zum
erlebnis werden das reine bauchladen
prinzip das reicht einfach nicht mehr
entscheidend wird auch sein inwieweit
die vermieter der galerie karstadt
kaufhof häuser über eine mietsenkung mit
sich reden lassen und je nach ergebnis
könnten weitere filialen auf der kippe
stehen kein gutes omen für die
innenstädte
zumal andere ketten wie esprit und
hallhuber auch schon gläubigerschutz
beantragt haben
dankeschön nach frankfurt valerie von
einem beziehungsweise zwei sehr alten
unternehmen kommen wir zu einem noch
sehr jungen und zudem sehr erstaunlichen
frage wie kann man zwei milliarden
verlieren und angeblich weiß keiner wo
sie geblieben sind nun irgendjemand wird
es wissen aber noch ist nicht klar wer
der skandal um den deutschen technik
konzerne wirecard ist ein regelrechter
wirtschaftskrimi selbst hartgesottene
börsianer
die schon wirklich viel erlebt haben
zeigen sich einigermaßen fassungslos
der langjährige wirecard chef der das
unternehmen vom star zum dax konzern
geführt hatte trat heute zurück
alexander pohl berichtet als markus
braun das letzte mal als chef von
wirecard vor eine kamera tritt hat er
seinen gesamten vorstand mit dabei
sie alle sind auf der suche nach zwei
milliarden euro die scheinbar über nacht
verschwunden sind
es kann derzeit nicht ausgeschlossen
werden dass die wirecard ag in einem
betrugsfall erheblichen ausmaßes zum
geschädigten geworden ist betrug so viel
scheint sicher wer der betrogene und wer
der betrüger ist nach wie vor unklar
die asiatischen banken die das geld
haben sollten führen wirecard nicht als
kunden alle konto belege seien gefälscht
sagen sie dass sich zwei milliarden euro
in luft auflösen oder nie da waren
unvorstellbar für einen dax konzern
es kann eigentlich nicht sein dass eine
firma wie wirecard nicht merkt dass zwei
milliarden euro nicht auf ihren konten
lagern dass sie dafür einen
wirtschaftsprüfer braucht ist
unvorstellbar ich frage mich wie das
widert die kontrollsysteme tatsächlich
funktioniert haben sollen
offensichtlich überhaupt nicht fast
jedem ist wirecard schon mal begegnet
hinter vielen bargeldlosen zahlungen
steckt der dienstleister aus aschheim
bei münchen
markus braun die schillernde gründer
figur hat aus einer kleinen firma einen
tech konzern geformt der es mit den
großen aus dem silicon valley aufnehmen
konnte das war ein start up das dann
tolle ergebnisse gebracht hat tolle
umsätze hatte in den dax geschossen ist
das war 2018
schon während dieser erfolgsgeschichte
die ersten ungereimtheiten wirecard
mitarbeiter in asien sollen von 2016 an
scheingeschäfte getätigt bilanzen
gefälscht und gelder veruntreut haben
das berichtet die financial times
wirecard streitet alles ab
der steile aufstieg so der eindruck
bekam burkhardt dennoch nicht die
struktur nicht einem dax-unternehmen
angepasst und deswegen hat man einfach
auch die vorschriften die man dort zu
erfüllen hat dann nicht ausreichend
erfüllt es war einmal ein shooting star
heute ermittelt die staatsanwaltschaft
anleger drohen mit milliarden klagen am
ende steht vielleicht der abstieg aus
dem dax
nach dem rücktritt des vorstandschefs
ist aufklärung nötiger denn je
am schluss ist es so dass wirecard
tatsächlich eines der unternehmen ist
auf die wir eigentlich setzen sollten
das ist ein zukunfts und
neben technologie im zahlungs
dienstleistungsbereich wir wissen ja
dass unsere banken momentan tatsächlich
auf dem absteigenden ast sind wirecard
hat man eigentlich eine rosige zukunft
zugebilligt dass diese zukunft noch
rosig werden kann hängt entscheidend
davon ab ob die neue firmenspitze aus
den fehlern der vergangenheit gelernt
hat der verfassungsschutz beobachtet
brandenburgs afg chef andreas kalbitz
genauso wie seinen parteifreund volker
in thüringen
das stört viele in der afg nicht dass
die beiden rechtsextremisten sind
sondern dass der verfassungsschutz immer
größere teile der partei
im visier hat für noch mehr ärger sorgt
allerdings dass jörg merten als einer
der beiden bundesparteichefs versucht
kalbitz auf formal juristischem wege
loszuwerden
seitdem wird in der afc ein offener
machtkampf ausgetragen mit noch offenen
ausgang afd parteichefs die sich mit den
extremsten unter den radikalen anlegten
ist das in der vergangenheit allerdings
nicht so gut sogar dass für olten
ausgehen wird freundlich ihn gleich
selbst doch zunächst berichtet david
gebhard vom heutigen gerichtsurteil mit
dem kallwitz zunächst einen juristischen
punktsieg heran
die afg bezeichnet sich selbst gerne als
rechtsstaatspartei heute muss ein
gericht feststellen dass sie es selbst
mit dem recht wohl nicht so genau
genommen hat
das entscheidende war dass das gericht
mit dem heutigen urteil dem eilantrag
des antragstellers lang kabels gegen die
afg im wesentlichen recht gegeben hat
der mit knapper mehrheit vom
bundesvorstand geschafft andreas kalbitz
darf erstmal auf die mitglied bleiben
und frohlockt zuerst freue ich mich mal
über diese rechtsstaatliche entscheidung
die unsere rechtsauffassung auch
bestätigt hat das ist ein gutes und
wichtiges signal für die partei das
sieht er auch so willkommen zurück
triumphiert türen höcke kalbitzer
geführten zusammen den inzwischen
aufgelösten parteiflügel die in der
verfassungsschutz als
rechtsextremistisch einstuft und der
informell weiter besteht
nun bekommt der partei rechtsaußen
kallwitz gewisse parteirechte wieder
eingeräumt bis zu einer entscheidung des
partei gerichts
wir erwarten jetzt die entscheidung des
parteilichen nahe des
bundesschiedsgerichts der partei und das
wird in kürze entscheiden
das ist die eigentlich entscheidende
geschichte ist das hier wäre dann ein
partieller etappenerfolg allenfalls aber
ich sehe nicht weiß dass darin die
kallwitz gegner glauben weiter dass
kallwitz am ende fliegt für die kalbitz
getreuen sind sie längst zu hass figuren
geworden demonstrative rückendeckung
gemeinsame auftritte mit kalbitz zuletzt
in sachsen als ohrfeige für morgen
storch und kuba ist kameradschaft mehr
als nur ein wort und ich stehe zu dir
und gehen durch dick und dünn mit dir
als co-chef kino kubala kann heute kaum
noch verbergen dass er mit leuten
eigentlich durch ist muss ja bedeuten
zurücktreten
das entscheide ich nicht kann sie
fordern sie sind ja immerhin co
vorsitzender der partei
da sage ich jetzt nichts so wird jörg
worten von einigen mehr oder weniger
verklausuliert nahegelegt persönliche
konsequenzen zu ziehen
diejenigen die mit juristisch
fragwürdigen mitteln versuchen jemanden
auszuschließen müssen sich überlegen wie
sie jetzt weiter mit diesem thema
umgehen ist vor allem jetzt aufgefordert
den bundesvorstand zu überzeugen dass
die juristischen spielchen die vates
gemacht haben der partei schadet und wie
das tödlichste beenden sollten das ist
seine hauptaufgabe jetzt wenn er nach
einer aufgabe hat in der afg ist die
stimmung seit wochen vergiftet die
gräben tief in der engsten parteiführung
redet man nicht mehr mit sondern
übereinander und das schlecht es geht
längst darum wer bleiben kann und wer
gehen muss
und das meisten ist uns jörg merten
zugeschaltet dort in der nähe von meißen
findet morgen ein parteikonvent stadt
guten abend herr melden guten abend herr
alexander gauland hatte gesagt
diejenigen die das losgetreten haben für
die wird schwierig wenn kalbitz vor
einem gericht erfolg hat wie schwierig
wird es denn jetzt für sie na ja also es
wird darauf ankommen wenn in der sache
entschieden wird und in der sache ist
heute nicht entschieden worden wir sind
eigentlich mit dem gerichts oder gar
nicht unzufrieden der im hauptantrag von
kallwitz ist der antrag heute abgewiesen
worden
die digi seien seine hilfsantrag der
wurde positiv beschieden
das heißt er kann jetzt für eine gewisse
zeit wieder die mitgliedsrechte haben
aber eben auch nur für eine gewisse zeit
ist seine art gnadenfrist entscheidend
für uns war das ein partei gerecht das
bundesschiedsgericht entscheidet und da
hat das gericht heute haargenau gesagt
das bundesschiedsgericht muss in der
hauptsache entscheiden das hat sich
selbst in der sache ja gar nicht
festgelegt das wird von vielen jetzt im
ersten moment offensichtlich falsch
aufgefasst
aber es ist tatsächlich so dass in der
hauptsache überhaupt noch nicht
verhandelt und entschieden wurde das
kommt aber sie sind wir sind sehr
zuversichtlich dass wir eine hauptsache
recht bekommen aber sie werden jetzt
nicht den heutigen gerichts in schuss
dass er morgen erstmal wieder die
parteien darf beziehungsweise der
parteiausschluss annulliert wurde als
als niederlage für ihn interpretieren
oder nein das ist aus unserer sicht ist
das der wermutstropfen das ist
tatsächlich so hätte ich mir anders
gewünscht aus wenn ich gar keinen hehl
machen aber das ist nicht das
entscheidende das entscheidend ist dass
er in seinem hauptantrag abgewiesen
wurde und das in der hauptsache selbst
das bundesschiedsgericht entscheidet und
da gehe ich mit großer sicherheit davon
aus dass es unsere argumentation folgen
wird weil die wirklich lieb und
stichfestes und sattelfest ist und dann
wird die mitgliedschaft von andreas
kalbitz wahrscheinlich auch beendet sein
nun hatte ich gerade heute bleibt der
partei gesagt ich meinte natürlich herr
kalbitz
am morgen aber auf jeden fall ich gar
nicht gemerkt das werden wir ja sehen
das ist eine interessante frage
denn sie haben für sehr viel ärger in
ihrer partei gesorgt eine spaltung wird
ihnen vorgeworfen morgen bei dem konvent
wird zum beispiel aus niedersachsen
einen antrag geben wovon
parteischädigenden und zersetzenden
verhalten die regel ist also wie
isoliert sind sie inzwischen in der afc
also ich habe zunächst einmal klare
mehrheitsverhältnisse im bundesvorstand
und ich weiß auch ich bin in den
parteien natürlich sehr sehr gut
vernetzt ich weiß darum dass ich da
gegner habe das bleibt auch nicht aus
wenn man einen so klaren kurs fällt wie
ihn fahre ich weiß aber die mehrheit der
partei hinter mehr dass bei der
entscheidung des bundesvorstandes
gemerkt dass unglaublich viele
gratulationen sagte das ist richtig es
war überfällig
ihr musste das machen schön dass ihr den
mut gefunden habe das war sehr wichtig
für die partei das problem ist gern
gesehen weil die empörten natürlich
lauter sind
die entführten sind ja nicht irgendwer
also mehrheiten da gibt es nur
meeresschutz aber es gibt natürlich auch
ein unterschiedliches gewicht an ihrer
seite stand frau von storch aber die
prominenten schwergewichte die anderen
kubala bauland weidl und dann die
diversen landesvorsitzenden allen voran
herr höcker und natürlichkeit ist selbst
auch die standen gegen sie das ist meist
kein gutes zeichen für einen parteichef
land eine spaltung an diesen linien
entlang läuft und die wir im vorstand
mit ihnen bestimmt haben das waren jetzt
mit verlaub eher unbekannt
parteimitglieder vorsicht vorsicht
vorsicht im bundesvorstand ist jedes
mitglied gleichberechtigt gleich gleich
stimmberechtigt und hier ist eine
mehrheit die das entschieden hat und
wenn sie die landesvorsitzenden
ansprechen dann ist herr hätte
sicherlich ein sehr lauter
landesvorsitzende aber bitte übersehen
sie nicht dass er einen kleinen
landesverband anführt und dass er
bundespolitisch schlicht keine rolle
spielt wir haben etliche andere
landesvorsitzende die definitiv meine
meine position teilen die könnte ich ihn
eher verlauf zählen aber ich glaube das
würde unsere sendezeit darüber schreiben
wenn sie das denn ernst dass herr höcker
eigentlich der afg bundespolitisch keine
rolle spielt man jetzt nicht formal ich
meine von seinem politischen gewicht
dass sich ja sogar der verfassungsschutz
anders
schauen sie weg ist thüringischer
landesvorsitz und der historische
fraktionsvorsitzender
er hat noch nie an der programmarbeit
der partei mitgearbeitet er gehört der
programmkommission nicht an er ist war
noch nie in einen bundesfachausschuss er
war noch nie im bundesvorstand er ist
nicht im bundestag
er ist kein bundespolitiker er ist ein
landespolitiker der sehr laut
vernehmlich ist aber ist so einen
bundespolitiker und der wirft ihnen vor
sie würden sich mit politischen gegnern
verbrüdern hätte würde das
wahrscheinlich feind zeugen nennen dass
so ein begriff den jeder gerne verwendet
ja das ist eine irrige vorstellung ich
tue genau das was ich auf dem
bundesparteitag in braunschweig bei der
letzten bundesvorstands wahl gesagt habe
da habe ich gesagt wir müssen eine klare
brandmauer zu rechtsextremen positionen
haben führen die stehe ich wer damit
nicht einverstanden ist er darf mich
nicht wählen
und siehe da ich bin mit 404
delegiertenstimmen gewählt worden
das war die höchste zahl an delegierten
stimmen aller bundesvorstandsmitglieder
die gewählt wurden ich habe da eine
mehrheit in einer partei und zwar eine
deutliche mehrheit der partei hinter mir
die habe ich auch jetzt hinter mir das
weiß ich und das spüre ich lasse träge
jeden tag an rückhalt aus der partei
gespiegelt so ähnlich hat mir das sehr
locker und frau petri vor jeweils
mehreren jahren am heute schon alle auch
erklärt und dann waren sie ganz schnell
weg der unterschied ist dass das logo
und petri mit dem kopf durch die wand
wollte sie sehen ja die waren auch
relativ schnell weg ich mache jetzt die
position des bundes sprecher der partei
seit fünf jahren am vierten juli werden
das fünf jahre dass ich das mache
und das hat gründe dass die gründe
liegen darin dass ich ein teamspieler
bin und dass ich mir auch ein mit dass
ich auch mit einem team zusammenarbeitet
das haben logo und petrini gemacht die
haben als solitäre versucht ihren willen
der partei aufzurücken und so geht das
nicht in der partei der unteren geht das
also mal nicht da braucht man schon den
rückhalt aus der partei selbst
das habe ich erkennen bei anders gemacht
darum bin ich auch noch da
dann werden wir sehen ob das so bleibt
erhalten dann gibt's für das interview
ich danke ihnen schönen abend noch
das interview haben wir vor einer stunde
geführt
bei der cdu gab es heute einen rückzug
ob das nur ein karriereknick ist oder
das ende eines sehr schnellen und
steilen aufstiegs wird sich zeigen aus
den großen ambitionen die philipp am tor
hatte wird jedenfalls erstmal nichts
er verzichtete am abend auf die
kandidatur für den chefposten seiner
partei in mecklenburg vorpommern von
dort berichten jetzt anja kinos und
susanne seidel güstrow nach der sitzung
des cdu landesvorstandes philipp am tor
zieht konsequenzen aus den lobbyismus
vorwürfen gegen ihn
das wohl seiner partei stehe über
persönlichen ambitionen
deshalb habe ich mich an dieser stelle
entschieden dass ich für das amt des
landesvorsitzenden der cdu mecklenburg
vorpommern nicht zur verfügung stehen
der persönliche druck den man aushalten
was ich wohl für ihn so groß geworden
und auch die einschätzung dass die
landespartei dadurch schaden nimmt das
er dann diesen schritt gegangen ist und
das kann man nur mit respekt bewerten
amthor ein hoffnungsträger für die cdu
im nordosten bislang jetzt in der klemme
seit bekannt ist dass er als
bundestagsabgeordneter in nebentätigkeit
für eine us firma gearbeitet und sich
bei der bundesregierung für diese
eingesetzt hatte
medien berichteten über aktienoptionen
die am tor von der us firma erhielt und
über angebliche luxus reisen unter
anderem nach korsika
die berliner generalstaatsanwaltschaft
und die bundestagsverwaltung prüfen den
fall
bislang hat er keinen reinen tisch
gemacht es geht nicht darum ein paar
fragen in cdu zirkeln zu beantworten
sondern deutlich zu machen was da
gelaufen ist denn letztendlich stehen
hier integrität und glaubwürdigkeit von
politik auf dem spiel
die landes cdu hielt trotz aller kritik
lange am kandidaten am tor fest denn der
hatte im politikverdrossenen vorpommern
aus dem stand 2017 ein direktmandat
gewonnen unterhält beste kontakte in die
parteispitze und machte im bundestag mit
seinen reden auf sich aufmerksam so ein
fahrer sich als kandidat für den
cdu-vorsitz in einem landesverband mit
einer dünnen personaldecke auch in
ueckermünde in seinem vorpommerschen
wahlkreis ist philipp amtes tätigkeit
für die us-firma thema also ich nicht
hier für betriebe in sätzen wie hoch was
brauchen dafür liegen ja man ist schon
ein bisschen enttäuscht wird mal sagen
aber ich glaube ich würde trotzdem noch
hinter ihm stehen bürger man so eine
position stück wie er auch wenn man ein
junger mensch ist muss einem bewusst
sein dass mein vogel 2 muss nach dem
rückzug des kandidaten amt nominiert die
cdu noch am abend den landrat michael
sack für den job als parteichef und
sucht so dem weg aus der führungskrise
gut ein jahr vor der nächsten
landtagswahl
und jetzt macht erstmal gundela weiter
mit den nachrichten und den beginn mit
dem heutigen eu gipfel
die eu staats und regierungschefs haben
sich bei ersten beratungen über die
geplanten milliardenschweren corona
hilfen nicht einigen können
eu-ratspräsident michelle hofft dass ein
gipfeltreffen mitte juli klarheit bringt
bundeskanzlerin merkel erklärte nach der
video konferenz die verhandlungen seien
sehr schwierig die eu stehe vor der
größten wirtschaftlichen herausforderung
ihrer geschichte
strittig ist unter anderem wie die
geplanten 750 milliarden euro verteilt
werden ob als zuschüsse oder als kredite
die zurückgezahlt
der bundestag hat in erster lesung über
das corona konjunkturpaket und den
zweiten nachtragshaushalt beraten die
finanzminister scholz verteidigte die
maßnahmen und die geplanten rekord
schulden von über 218 milliarden euro es
gehe um die gesundheit und wohlstand und
die zukunft deutschlands
linke und grüne forderten dagegen
nachbesserungen für mehr soziale
gerechtigkeit
die afg kritisierte die massiv steigende
staatsverschuldung die fdp auch den so
wörtlich im bürokratischen aufwand für
die mehrwertsteuersenkung wegen der
korona krise sind die steuereinnahmen
des staates eingebrochen im mai im
schnitt um fast 20 prozent gegenüber dem
vorjahresmonat beim bund betrug das
minus fast 35 prozent einnahmen aus
lohn- und umsatzsteuer gehen zurück weil
millionen menschen in kurzarbeit sind
nach dem krone ausbruch in der
fleischfabrik tönnies im landkreis
gütersloh ermittelt die
staatsanwaltschaft bielefeld wegen des
anfangsverdachts der fahrlässigen
körperverletzung weiter hieß sind von 11
100 getesteten mitarbeitern 800 und 3
positiv
weitere 5000 sollen auch mit hilfe von
bundeswehr soldaten so schnell wie
möglich getestet werden
mehrere schulen und kitas im landkreis
gütersloh wurden geschlossen
da auch kinder von terni es mitarbeitern
positiv getestet wurden tausende
menschen in der region stehen unter
quarantäne
die ministerpräsident laschet
durchsetzen will wir appellieren an alle
diese quarantäne auch einzuhalten
und wenn sie nicht eingehalten wird
werden wir mit allen uns zur verfügung
stehenden mittel diese quarantäne
durchsetzen im kampf gegen
kindesmissbrauch fordern die
innenminister von bund und ländern die
wiedereinführung der umstrittenen
vorratsdatenspeicherung von telefon- und
internetverbindungen unter vorbehalt
eines urteils des europäischen
gerichtshofs zudem erklärten sich bei
der konferenz in erfurt mehrere
bundesländer bereit flüchtlings
kinder von den griechischen inseln
aufzunehmen im mittelmeer sucht derweil
das deutsche rettungsschiff swatch 3
nach einem sicheren hafen zum anlegen an
bord mehr als 200 menschen vor libyen
aus seenot gerettet
heute ist der erste bundesweite digital
tag eine art aktionstag umschwung in die
bundesdeutsche digitalisierung zu
bringen in den kann sie allerdings
gebrauchen stichwort breitbandausbau
stichwort funklöcher und so weiter
darüber reden wir ja alles schon seit
jahren besonders augenfällig wurde das
jetzt während der schulschließungen
sowie die korona krise ja eh wie ein
brennglas ausleuchtet wo stärken und
schwächen eines landes liegen über den
schulen jedenfalls sah man wie viel dann
noch im argen liegt wie man wünscht sich
dass kinder dauerhaft homeschooling
machen und nur am computer lernen aber
vielerorts fehlte es ja schon an den
technischen voraussetzungen um überhaupt
digitales lernen anzubieten peter böhme
berichtet lehrerin anne goggles im
corona unterricht online von daheim
gesellschaftslehre mit einer fünften
klasse den unterricht im eigenen
arbeitszimmer hier macht sie lieber als
in der schule
gerade in der schule wusste ich dann
nicht unbedingt dass das ist dann
funktionstüchtig ist
beispielsweise hatten wir schon mal
situationen das auf einmal die server
zusammengebrochen sind 200 megabit
bandbreite hat ihr zwei personen
haushalt 200 megabit bandbreite hat auch
ihre gesamtschule in hürth aber für 730
schüler und 80 lehrer eigentlich ist die
schule digital top ausgestattet 200
stationäre computer sogar ein paar
laptops aber was nützt die schönste
technik wenn man sie nicht nutzen kann
wenn mehrere klassen gleichzeitig ins
netz gehen
es gibt zehn minuten da können die
schüler arbeiten dann gibt es die
situation da ist der baum durch die
seiten nicht mehr auf dann eine
viertelstunde da ist dann eigentlich
kein arbeiten ermöglicht es wird unruhig
irgendwie man kommt nicht weiter man
kann die aufgaben nicht
nicht erledigen dann aber nach einer
viertelstunde geht es wieder weil
vielleicht eine klasse aus dem raum
ausgegangen ist und die rechner
ausgeschaltet hat sie bräuchten
bandbreiten im gigabit bereich sagen sie
das problem ist ein bundesweites zeigt
eine zdf umfrage in den bundesländern in
berlin etwa hat noch keine einzige
schule überhaupt einen dsl-anschluss nur
in vier ländern gibt es laut der
antworten derzeit gigabit bandbreite bei
einem eher überschaubaren prozentsatz
der schule alles dauernd auch beim
digital packt der soll schulen technisch
fit machen mit geldern etwa für wlan
netze oder digitales equipment
vorgesehen sind fünf milliarden euro für
fünf jahre
bisher wurden aber weniger als 300
millionen euro beantragt die hälfte
allein aus nrw und sachsen
wir sehen aber auch dass wenn ich so
viele anträge haben wie wir uns das
wünschen würden das ist ganz klar das
liegt aber auch an verschiedenen punkten
zum einen ist es so dass die anträge gut
begründet sein müssen weil es nicht sinn
macht irgendwo geld hin zu stecken
sondern es soll dann auch sinnvoll und
medienpädagogisch sinnvoll angewendet
werden
natürlich sind diejenigen die die
anträge gerade arbeitet 23 monaten sehr
beschäftigt mit corona mit der
bewältigung der krise mehr technik heißt
aber nicht automatisch auch mehr
kompetenz sagt der bildungsexperte
oliver fink selbst lehrer
er bildet pro jahr 700 kollegen im
digitalen unterricht aus viele von ihnen
seien motiviert und lernt freudig für
andere sei der weg in die digitale welt
schwierig dazu gehört natürlich auch was
wenn ich selber nicht so vertraut damit
bin mich dann für schülerinnen und
schüler zu stellen bei denen ich weiß
dass die meisten von denen digitale
kompetenz sind da habe ich auch eine
ganz gute chance mich zu blamieren
beziehungsweise dass mir jetzt was nicht
gelingt
an der höhe der gesamtschule haben sie
trotz corona den unterricht gemanagt
analog und digital aber zukunftsschule
es gibt viele hürden in deutschland und
es geht langsam und genau gegenüber der
schule in herthas der peter böhme gerade
berichtet hat liegt eine andere schule
und da funktioniert das digitale lernen
deutlich besser wird wurden mit viel
energie schon frühzeitig konzepte
entwickelt und ideen die man sich besser
ausstatten kann das zeigt dominik müller
russe
sehr vielseitig und dynamisch läuft eine
unterrichtsstunde bei annika bucher
mathe sport und bio in einem
es geht heute ums thema pulsfrequenz und
noch mehr passiert digital tabellen
erstellen gemeinsame datenanalysen und
wenn annika buche mal eine frage nicht
selbst beantworten kann ruft sie eine
expertin an
in diesem fall die mutter eines schülers
eine ärztin
es macht einfach viel mehr spaß uns
interessanter und abwechslungsreicher
und deshalb freut man sich ja viel macht
den unterricht nicht irgendwo text
versteht das ganze nicht so wimmelt
lernvideos und dann ich habe mich
einfach das gefühl ich lerne dadurch
viel besser eine attraktive
lernatmosphäre für die kinder eine
herausforderung für die lehrer
einstudierte pfade hinter sich zu lassen
die eingliederung von digitalen medien
in den unterricht ist eigentlich ist
eigentlich einfach allerdings so geht es
mir und meinen kollegen fast jeden tag
muss man sich auch als lehrkraft ein
bisschen neu erfinden man stößt vor neue
herausforderungen von neuer umgebung man
wann man hat auch weniger
handlungssicherheit sei routine nicht
eingeschlossen sind
auf der anderen seite ist das total
spannend weil ganz viele neue räume und
möglichkeiten entstehen die man
ausschöpfen kann wie haben sie diesen
sprung hinbekommen am albert schweitzer
gymnasium in hürth bei köln in eine neue
welt von der so viele andere schulen
träumen sie haben ihrem digital team
viel zeit und ressourcen frei geräumt
über zweieinhalb jahre ein sinnvolles
konzept zu erarbeiten und sie haben den
transformationsprozess auf viele
schultern verteilt haben ein 20-köpfiges
trainerteam ausgebildet das jetzt
ansprechpartner ist für alle digital
nicht zu affinen kollegen
sobald im alltag eine frage aufkommt ein
problem auf kommt dann kann ich hier was
gerade sehen kann nicht hier hingehen
und kann die menschen fragen wo ich weiß
sie haben eine antwort für mich und da
kann mir gleich geholfen werden
und das ist eben gut wenn man
eine sache in die breite bringen
natürlich muss auch die ausstattung
stimmen das albert schweitzer gymnasium
konnte externe firmen überzeugen sie mit
technik zu unterstützen mit einer 1
gigabit anbindung etwa das wichtigste
aber die eigenen kolleginnen und
kollegen ins boot zu holen und dann ist
ganz wichtig dass man den leuten nichts
auf drückt sondern sie im prinzip
überzeugt dass das ganze möglichen
vorteil hat dass ich dadurch arbeit ja
nicht zusätzliche arbeiter gibt sondern
arbeit spart im prinzip und man
unterricht dadurch interessanter und
teilweise sogar effektiver gestalten
kann machen ist ihre devise und sich
nicht abschrecken lassen
ich hatte diverse stunden die nicht
funktioniert haben das war aber
überhaupt nicht schlimm weil die kinder
sind sehr geduldig und die arbeiten
super mit und suchen auch nach lösungen
sind sehr dankbar und man selber lernt
in jeder stunde neu dazu man muss nicht
es muss nicht alles perfekt sein zu
begehen sondern es einfach ausprobieren
und mutig sein
ein ständiger lernprozess was lässt sich
weiter verbessern im digitalen
klassenraum am ziel sind auch sie noch
lange nicht
und jetzt nochmal mit anderen meldungen
des tages in vielen städten der usa
versammeln sich in diesen stunden
menschen um des endes der sklaverei zu
gedenken
am 19 juni 1865 hatte ein general der
unionstruppen in texas die freilassung
aller sklaven verkündet seither ein
inoffizieller gedenkt tag der in diesem
jahr mitten in die proteste gegen
rassismus feld schwarze leben zählen
lautet die botschaft in new york und in
anderen städten landesweit fordern sie
veränderungen nach dem gewaltsamen tod
des afro amerikaners george freut
bmw baut in diesem jahr 6000 stellen vor
allem an deutschen standorten ab und
will sich von 10.000 leiharbeitern
trennen
wegen des corona bedingten monate langen
stopps der produktion und der
absatzeinbrüche rechnet der autobauer
mit roten zahlen zunächst in diesem
quartal
der arbeitsplatzabbau soll durch
fluktuation und freiwillige
vereinbarungen erfolgen
deutschland will die entwicklung von
grünem wasserstoff als klimafreundliche
energieträger fördern im rahmen der
wasserstoff strategie wird sich künftig
ein
beim bund um die vernetzung von
forschung wirtschaft und politik kümmern
im auftrag von forschungsministerin
carlitscheck soll der cdu
bundestagsabgeordnete stefan kaufmann
als innovations- beauftragte diese neue
technologie vorantreiben
seine romane roman reihe der friedhof
der vergessenen bücher machte carlos
ruiz zafón zum wohl erfolgreichsten
spanischen schriftsteller der gegenwart
in seiner wahlheimat los angeles erlag
der katalane jetzt einer krebserkrankung
im alter von 55 jahren
das auftakt- werk der reihe der schatten
des windes wurde in 40 sprachen
übersetzt und weltweit 15 millionen mal
verkauft nach don quichote der
erfolgreichste spanische roman aller
zeiten
jedes einzelne buch hat eine seele heißt
es darin
die seele dessen der es geschrieben hat
und die seele derer die es gelesen und
erlebt und von ihm geträumt haben ja das
was von uns weiter geht es jetzt mit der
drama serie deutscher das drehbuch
beruht auf dem szenario dass in
deutschland eine stramm rechts
populistische partei die bundestagswahl
gewinnt sogar mit absoluter mehrheit
für zwei familien ändert sich damit das
leben auf unterschiedliche weise und
gegen mitternacht meldet sich ein
letztes mal heute plus dann heute
schnell geht es dann morgen wieder auf
wiedersehen
[Musik]
genau meine damen und herren jetzt zum
wochenende ändert sich das wetter denn
das tief octavia zieht weiter nach
nordwesten und nimmt den regen mit und
das hoch urs breitet sich von der
iberischen halbinsel schon richtung
frankreich aus und zusammen mit dem tief
über dem atlantik den tief viola bringt
es uns dann nächste woche den sommer
heute nacht feld östlich der elbe noch
regen sonst sind einige schauer
unterwegs und die temperaturen sinken
auf werte zwischen 16 und 8 grad
die acht grad gibt es am alpenrand
morgen liegen die höchstwerte meist
knapp über 20 grad es gibt kleine
ausreißer zum beispiel am alpenrand oder
auch an der ostsee und in schleswig
holstein
da werden nur 19 grad erreicht morgen
fällt im äußersten osten noch etwas
regen das kann auch mal ein gewitter
dabei sein aber zwischen schleswig
holstein nordrhein westfalen scheint
schon häufig die sonne und am sonntag
beschränkten sich einzelne regenschauer
doch wirklich auf den äußersten osten
zwischen usedom und dem oderbruch oder
auch auf die region zwischen dem
berchtesgadener land und im
wettersteingebirge bei 20 bis 26 grad
und dann wird es in der kommenden woche
sehr sonnig und von tag zu tag wärmer
am mittwoch liegen die temperaturen bei
25 bis 33 grad
und wenn sie sich jetzt fragen wie es
weitergeht hier am temperaturen und
wettertrend für berlin sehen sie ganz
eindeutig das wetter dieses sommerwetter
hält doch wohl bis zum nächsten
wochenende durch damit wünsche ich ihnen
jetzt einen schönen abend und ein
schönes wochenende